okay so it's a little bit under s and
Eric we're both here in the audience
I'll talk about the boats model and the
Swenson rank algorithm so everybody saw
these models just two quick slides
eating model label vertices by plus or
minus red or green red or blue a weight
of the configuration is B to the number
of monochromatic edges and we are
interested in sampling from the
distribution sports model the same thing
except you have more than two colors ok
so maybe three maybe four whatever and
again you count the number of
monochromatic edges wait if a
configuration is B to die I'll talk
maybe a little bit about general spin
models so a general spin model you have
some number Q which is the number of
spins this is an interaction matrix B
with non-negative entries then you are
looking at labelings of the vertices of
the graph by the spins one up to Q and
the weight of the configuration is just
product over all edges you look at the
entry in the matrix B 1 and point the
other endpoint and that's the wages of
coffee
sure for the eating model you will have
2 by 2 matrix like this for pot model
you will have a 3 by 3 or 4 by 4 or 5 by
5 matrix like that okay so we can look
at many spin models and there are lots
of interesting questions you can ask so
this question I guess you would ask is
is it easy to sample from the model on
general grass sometimes this is possible
for example for a ferromagnetic easing
model which is possible but more often
it's not possible okay so for most
models we are unable to sample from the
distribution of the model on general
graph so I guess we have to look at more
constraints on the graph now one such
constraint that seems to be good is
looking at the maximum degree ok so for
maximum degree 5 graph sampling is easy
for maximum degree 6 graph it's
difficult for the independent sets model
but you can I mean that this is more of
a complexity question complexity
questions are usually pretty difficult
sometimes you can get some insight from
easier questions about the dynamics like
how do dynamics behave on grass so for
example for independent sets we know
that for maximum degree for grass the
global dynamics which is the chain that
only flips one vertex at the time is
rapidly mixing on the other hand for
random six regular grass it's slow
maybe if analyzing the global dynamics
on maximum degree delta graph is too
difficult it might be easier to look at
random grass if you want to understand
dynamics on random graphs well then it
would be helpful to understand how the
typical configurations of the model look
on on the random graph and global
dynamics is not the only chain that you
can use so we are going to explore what
are the Markov chains you can use now so
these are the motivating questions for
why I'm going to do what I'm going to do
but I want to have a yet simpler
question okay so we are going to look at
this means he'll models so what does
mean field model mean that means that
I'm going to look at the model on the
complete graph okay now that makes
things nice and symmetric very easy we
are going to have to repair a mattress
the model to get interesting behavior
okay so when you when you study a spin
model on general graphs usually you fix
the interaction matrix and you studied
for it for all graphs or maybe all
graphs of some maximum degree well here
if this n goes to infinity you have to
make the interaction weaker and weaker
as you get more and more vertices and I
guess for pots model and easing model
there is a accepted way of doing it ok
so the interaction for the monochromatic
edges you take 1 plus some constant
legrand that constant alkyl be
differently I guess it's an interesting
define mean field model for a general
spin model i am not sure what what the
right thing is maybe taking like one
over end of each entry in the matrix is
n goes to infinity it's a good question
whether we can get some insight from
from this mean field for other models
okay so let's see let's go to them
sports / eating model so I'm looking at
the model on the complete graph it and
vertices I'm going to look at how a
configuration can look like well the
configuration has a son bunch of
vertices which big one bunch of vertices
which pin to bunch of vertices which
pink you the number of monochromatic
edges is easy to figure out from this
right there is no structure in the graph
and the weight of a configuration is
something like this for convenience i
replaced one plus b over n to x 1 minus
BN to negative of that quantity it's the
same thing ok so this is the model we
are going to be looking at and we are
not the first people to look at the
model so people looked at the questions
that were on the slide with questions
for the mean film model so you can ask
is global dynamics fast for the port
model for the easing model and of course
this would be I mean this is just a
motivating question okay so the answers
here are what is the mixing time of the
global dynamics on the mean-field model
okay so for easing model we know that
the global dynamics is fast fast fast up
to some critical point at that critical
point it has polynomial mixing time and
beyond the critical point the mixing
time is exponential for pot model
similar behavior really fast and log in
mixing time hit the threshold polynomial
mixing time and beyond the threshold its
exponential
the chain we are going to analyze this
is a little bit different so this is the
strength and Wang chain sure I guess
isn't rose because of connection between
the pots model and the random cluster
model but but we are not going to need
to understand the connection okay so
here is how the chain works so we have
some coloring over the vertices okay
this is a example then what we do is we
look at the set of model chromatic edges
then we are going to remove each edge
from this site with certain probability
one of the B and then we are going to
get some connected components and we are
going to assign a uniformly random color
to each of the components one step of
the chain now the nice thing here is
that the set of monochromatic edges that
we get from from one component is a
complete graph and then we are a
performing
calculation on this random complete on
this complete graph which is well
studied problem this is the erdos-renyi
random graph model so people looked at
this question 24 the easing model so
they showed that the eating model is
really really for the eating model
designs in rank dynamics is really
really fast up to some threshold at the
threshold it slows down to some
polynomial mixing time and beyond the
threshold well it gets really fast again
but not as fast as it was for small
I guess for comparison if you compare it
with the global dynamics okay the mixing
time beyond the threshold for the global
dynamics was exponential whereas here we
are going to have really fast mixing
time that's the deal of the science and
rank dynamics it's fast polynomial time
everywhere
I guess this is the these are the
results that we get is that for pot
model there are actually several
critical points it's not just one
critical point so there is some critical
point up to which the chain is fast at
the critical point it slows down to
polynomial and then it's exponential for
a while and there is another threshold
after which the chain is going to be
fast again
so in order to give you a little bit of
insight on how these things are proved I
have to understand the typical
configurations of the model okay so type
of a configuration is fraction of the
vertices that have spin one fraction of
the vertices that spin to fraction of
the vertices that have spin q you can
argue that actually the only interesting
configurations are ones where one color
has more weight than the other colors
and the other colors are about equal ok
so then what you can do is you can look
at the total weight of configurations
with this type you can plot a curve and
you are going to look at this curve and
try to infer what is going on with the
model so if you are below this first
threshold you are going to look and
there is going to be just one peak ok so
the dominant configurations are the ones
where a is 1 over Q all of these things
are one of a cue the configurations are
totally uniform there is there is no
correlations between the spins of
different side ok then you go a little
bit further and suddenly you will see
that there is a little peak that is
starting to grow here so that's a little
volcano starting to grow there ok and
you go slightly beyond and the volcano
is sticking out and now you have two
points ok and I guess this explains why
the global dynamics starts to be slow
because well if you are here that means
one color color dominate and there is no
way of escaping this peak by just small
moves
further further further and edit second
critical point what happens is that this
that the little maximum did you head for
the for the uniformed configurations
disappears and you only are left with
configurations which have one color
dominating now this is this is still a
problem for the global dynamics but it's
not an issue for the Swenson lag because
when Zhang Liang picks a component and
recolor it recolors it by a color which
is uniformly at random okay so you can
move between the peaks corresponding to
different colors
okay so that I guess looking at these
pictures you can understand why the
global dynamics behaves the way it
behaves if you want to understand how
swenson rank behaves you have to I guess
look more into the dynamics and the
thing that controls the behavior of the
dynamics is the behavior of the giant
component in the in the elders rainy
model okay so here is the here is a
useful thing okay so we understand that
if we have an address or any random
graph then if we have probability of
picking an edge to your brand versus
bigger than one then this is a giant
component and we pretty much understand
the size of this component and you take
this and you translate it into the
slides and rank dynamics and you are
going to see that the evolution of the
largest color class because they are
going to say well let's just hope that
there is one big color class and the
remaining ones are small and it's going
to happen the evolution of the largest
color class is governed by some function
f like this okay which is connected to
the [ __ ]
random graph model okay so there is some
function f that explains how the
dynamics behaves if if you assume that
you have just one large color class okay
so now you can now you can look at this
function f and you can look at the
function below the first threshold at
the first threshold between the
thresholds everything okay and you are
going to look at these pictures and
you're going to see that if you are
below the first threshold then there is
what are just 16 point okay of this
function if you are at the first
threshold there are 26 points okay if
you are between the thresholds there are
26 points 26 points and suddenly here
just 16 point okay so this is going to
explain why it's fast here maybe fast
here there are just two that in each
case that is just 16 point and the
dynamics is going to get to there in
this case there are two fixed points and
they're going to fight okay and what
happens exactly the the thresholds well
that's a little bit finer analysis okay
so let me not go too deep into details
how how these proofs go but just just a
high level overview okay so let's say if
you are below the first threshold below
that we call that uniqueness threshold
what is going to happen is that the
mixing time is going to be theta of one
so you are at some point what the value
here tells you is by how much does the
size of the largest component decreases
okay so it always decreases by a big
amount decreases decrease it decreases
the decree speeds up you hit here and
everything shatters and you are in the
uniform distribution and in off one
steps you are going to mix so the
explanation why the mixing time here is
of one is you are always decreasing and
this decreases pretty fast faster faster
it here and you are in a uniform
distribution
on the other hand if you are above the
second threshold okay so again we are
going to have drift towards this fixed
point but the but there is no no abrupt
place that will that will get us to the
fixed point quickly so what is going to
be happening is that we are getting
closer and closer and closer to the
fixed point but we are getting there
slower slower slower slower so we are
going to actually need about log n steps
to get within something like plus minus
square root of N and then plus minus
square root of n you are going to couple
because of the fluctuations and then you
are going to these two slides explain
why the why the chain is fix why the
chain is fast below the first fixed
point above the second fixed point edit
or the second critical point and why
there is a slight difference between the
running times
now understanding the dynamics between
the six points that's actually pretty
easy okay here you just need to show
that the mixing time is 0 and well I'm
cheating here we cannot quite prove this
ok it will be nice if we could prove
this but what we have is n to the death
of one okay but aside from that the
proof is well if you are in a
configuration around this point you are
going to stay there if you are in a
configuration around this point you are
going to stay there now the most
interesting two cases are at the
critical points and if you are at the
critical point the second critical point
the question is why why does the
dynamics escape from the from the
uniform distribution and if you if you
look at the derivative of this function
f as the at the uniform critical point
then this number here is bigger than one
when q is bigger than two it's x equal
to one when q is equal to two so that
explains why there is difference between
easing and the post model
everybody is bigger than one so even
though this is a fixed point in the in
the first order in the in the derivative
there is a little bit of drift so you
are going to be here maybe by some
stochastic effects you are going to get
a little bit of variation but then you
are just going to get booted from the
vicinity of that point and that's going
to happen in log n steps because the
distance is geometrically increasing so
the most interesting point is the
uniform with the uniqueness fig a
critical point here the mixing time is
polynomial what is going to eventually
happen is the chain is going to converge
to the uniform distribution and the
difficult part is arguing that the chain
will escape from around the majority
fixed point
now if you're at this point there is no
drift there is almost no drift so in
expectation if you look the size of the
largest color class is not going to
decrease in expectation okay so what we
are going to have to do is we have to we
are going to have to rely on variance to
to get us out from this point okay so so
expectation does nothing to us but there
is a lot of variance right because we
are picking a random sub graph in this
entered or any model so that gives us I
don't know square root of and very ends
maybe n to the one third variant so we
are getting a lot of variance the
variance aggregates is going to kick us
out far enough and then the drift is
going to take over and take us to the
uniform distribution ok now it's the
intuition we tried for few weeks or
maybe a month to make a proof which is a
we would follow this intuition but we
couldn't sir the only thing you can do
at that point this resort to a potential
function argument you figure out the
potential function which encode your
intuition and you suffer and prove a
bunch of inequalities but it the
potential function captures this
intuition okay so you find the potential
function the potential function what is
going to do is it's going to have
a big second derivative in in this bed
window okay and the second derivative is
going to make sure that the potential
function decreases in expectation
because of the variance in that window
and then you engineer the function that
outside the window well the
the function value also decreases in
expectation now because of the drift ok
so I think this is this is enough about
the about the roof so let me let me say
a few things about the random graph so
all this I guess the hope for the the
hope here is that we are going to get
some insight about the random graph from
from doing this and we are going to get
some inside ok so so the the question
that we would like to understand this
how does spin model behave on the random
Delta regular graph does the global
dynamics nix on the random Delta regular
gas the Swenson rank makes on a delta a
regular graph now before looking into
this question what we have to do is we
have to understand the typical
configurations of the model on the
random Delta regular graph so the mental
thing that you want to do is you want to
take a sample random Delta regular graph
you want to sample a random
configuration from the model and try to
understand how it looks now this is
usually done in a reverse way where you
look at configurations of certain type
then you are going to look at the
expected value of the weight of
configurations of this type over the
choice of the random graph you are going
to look at the second moment of this
quantity you are going to do a little
bit more work and then you are going to
get some statement that with high
probability the actual weight of
configurations of this tight in the
random graph is bigger equal than the
expected value
now if you look at the box model on a
random delta regular graph you are going
to perform this process you are going to
look at the first moment and you're
going to see the same pictures as you
saw for the mean-field model okay so the
main field model is providing you some
picture for the random delta regular
graph okay so there are going to be
again two thresholds and you are going
to see the same pictures okay again the
only interesting kinds of configurations
are where one color is dominating and
the rest of the colors are about equal
now you would like to infer from these
pictures that global dynamics is slow we
would like to infer that the Swenson one
dynamics is slow now unfortunately we
are unable to do that okay so you would
conjecture that the same things should
happen on the random Delta regular graph
has happened on on the mean field model
okay so you would like to hope that
global dynamics starting from this point
it should be slow okay so insulin bank
should be slow in the entire interval
now there are some things that are known
okay so we know that the global dynamics
is slow but we cannot quite go up to the
uniqueness point okay we know that the
Swenson bank is slow exactly at this
point where the uniform and the one
color dominating are about balanced okay
we also know something about some
hardness of computing the partition
function for graphs of maximum degree
Delta from this point and what is the
what is the main difficulty okay so why
do i why are we where we unable to do
the same thing for the random Delta
regular graph as we can do for for the
complete graph well we have trouble with
the second moment we are unable we are
unable to prove the second moment okay
point about this what's the point what
about this point so I mean we know from
this point on that approximating the
partition function on the on Delta
regular gas or graphs of maximum degree
Delta is sharp is hard is hardest bit
and this relies on the hardness of the
pot model on general graphs so this is
this is just using random what you do is
you take you take the reduction which
will be more sophisticated than this one
and you just replace everywhere text by
by random Delta regular graph just to
control the degree okay maybe you remove
some vertices of degree to make them
degree Delta minus 1 so that is have
stuff for connection
ok so I'm going to say a little bit
about the second moment why do we have
difficulty and when can we do it ok so
so we can we can establish the second
moment sometimes ok now how do we how do
you establish the how do you establish
the second moment well
we can establish the second moment for
configurations which are global Maxima
all of the first moment okay so this
would be can do we can establish the
second moment matching the square of the
first moment if and only if the
configurations are local maximum of the
first moment how this is done well we we
have the first moment that some bunch of
formulas you are going to sit down and
write them up and there is a connection
between the first moment some thing we
call scale expression which is some kind
of matrix norm for the interaction
matrix and the three recursions of the
model okay and undress is going to give
it talk about this where he will explain
these things more in the detail and why
why why this connection allows us to do
second moment at the maxima is well
because the second moment is like the
first moment except for the spin system
where the interaction matrix is the
tensor product of the interaction matrix
with itself okay and then if you and
there are some marginality constraints
if you drop them you're going to look
here and these matrix norms they tend to
rise and you are going to get your
second moment okay that's that's how we
can get second moment if we are at a
local maximum of the first moment
the reason why we can only do local
Maxima is that we only can understand
the global Maxima of these expressions
we have no way of we have no way of
putting the marginality constraints in
everybody okay with this I just high
level okay so i'm going to i'm going to
show you an example where actually the
second moment calculation can be done at
at all at all a maxima even the local
ones okay so so i'm going to have to
look at this whole and problems which
are pretty popular in the exact counting
but not so much in the approximate
counting and i guess the reason is
because we don't have any interesting
negative results I don't know why so
maybe they'll be popular soon okay so
what is Holland problem I'm going to
look at Holland problems which are
homogeneous so what we have is we have a
parameter delta which is the degree i
have a bunch of numbers as you have up
to F Delta then I'm going to be looking
at Delta regular graphs and then I have
a distribution on subsets of the edges
where the probability of a subset is f0
to the number of vertices withheld agree
0 f 1 to the number vertices of degree 1
f delta to the number of vertices of
degree delta ok so here is an example of
a holland problem okay let's say delta
is equal to 3 f 0 f 3 is 1 f1 f2 which
one fifth and this is going to be my
graph then I have learned how many edges
it is so there are 256 different
configurations and let's say this
configuration all the vertices of degree
0 so the configuration should have
weight proportional to 1 this has two
vertices of degree zero four vertices of
degree 2 the way it should be
proportional to 1 and 1 over 625 okay so
this is much like this a spin system
except now the edges are the ones which
are assigned spin zero and one and you
are measuring the weights on the on the
vertices okay so
so
example of a Holland problem well
matching zmanim a dimer problem would
fit in this framework okay if i have f
01 f 11 everything else 0 then the i'm
only allowing vertices of degree 0 and 1
so that the lid configurations are going
to be matchings i can encode perfect
matchings if I require all over this you
to be of degree 1 and now I would like
to understand how does a Holland problem
behave on the random Delta regular graph
ok so I'm going to play the same game as
I do for the spin system I look at a
signature of a configuration which is
the fraction of the vertices that they
have degree zero up to fraction of the
vertices which have degree Delta I'm
going to look at weight of dis
configurations in expectation over the
choice of the random graph and I would
like to know if the second moment works
or if I would like to know it whether
the second moment works so you know no
no expectation of you reading the
formula it's always a little bit of pain
I just want to get the big picture after
you you you the first moment you are
going to sit down and write an
expression and then you are going to
study the asymptotic growth of the decks
expression is a function of n ok and you
are going to you are going to get some
understanding ok what that is ok now the
second moment the same thing you are
going to write a bunch of
formulas and you are going to figure out
what the second moment is at least the
asymptotic growth rate okay and the
interesting thing here is that for these
problems actually the second moment is
always bounded by the square of the
first moment so here i have an example
of this first moment second moment
problem where the second moment always
works I am NOT going to go into the
proof deeply but just a idea how the
proof works okay so what you can do is
you look at the expression for the first
moment you look at the expression for
the second moment and you can express
the second moment as some kind of
entropy of some random variable on
binary strings and here you are looking
at the first bit of the string and you
look at the expression and if you
interpret these gammas whatever they are
as probabilities you are going to see
that this is some difference of two
entropy okay now you are going to look
at what the expression for the first
moment is and you are going to get the
dates the same thing except you are now
looking at entropy is not of the Joint
Distribution but individual variables
and then if you want to show that the
second moment is the most square of the
first moment in logarithm the logarithm
of the first moment less delicate than
twice the logarithm the second the
logarithm of the second moment was very
cool and twice the logarithm of the
first moment we are going to get some
inequality about mutual information and
you use some properties of the mutual
information and you are going to get it
in full generality okay so so sometimes
sometimes the second moment can work but
why doesn't it work for the Delta
regular glass and the inducements and
and the pot model I have no clue okay
so
I told you about these three ways of
looking at them at the model okay you
can look at the model through the first
moment you can look at the model to some
kind of scale for the expression you can
look at the model through three
recursions each view gives you different
different power ok so here it's
interesting that you can do the same
thing for the for the Holland problems
okay you can look at the first moment
you saw these things you can you can do
three recursions as well the three
recursions will have just two variables
or one variable is enough right because
you are only having in a subtree you are
looking at the weight of the sub tree if
the edge is present or the edge is not
present three recursions are going to be
with two variables if you want to keep
things in the collective space if you
want to take the ratio you can do that
but no it's nicer this way and you can
also get some kind of scale free
expression much like we get for spin
systems okay now since the first mode
since the second moment for this holland
problems works always it works not just
at the global Maxima battles at the
local Maxima okay if you want to
understand how Roland problem behaves on
the random Delta regular graph is that
you are going to take your f you are
going to take this function here you are
just going to plot it and if you see
that this function in the plot has two
Maxima then you're going to know that
the global dynamics is which is slow if
I global dynamics you mean the dynamics
that flips on edge each time so I would
like to have something like this for
still models as well understanding the
typical configurations through the scale
free expression and get an automatic
second moment
so that's the end I guess so these are
just the questions so why can't we get
hardness or slowness of global dynamics
in this interval or why can't we get
hardness of the thoughts model on
maximum degree Delta graphs in this
interval we can maybe go here but we are
not all the way to the unique extra shot
why why why do we have trouble with the
second moment for the spin systems what
is what is going on now understanding
the configurations on the random Delta
regular graph well that's enough for a
negative results now the positive
results that'sthat's way harder think
and just understanding the typical
configurations is not going to be
helpful so this is a much harder
question but what is it with swenson
rank for pots model is it fast on max
degree Delta graphs is it Delta regular
graph and i would like to also low so
this is the second time i see this
connection between three recursions
first moment and some kind of nice
expression is there something deeper
going on is this some kind of general
principle is the painless way of giving
these connections I think there must be
something it should be general right for
every good but it is there like any spin
system / Holland you will you without
any pain get the let's say there's some
kind of expression that you just can't
plot and understand how the model
behaves on the random Delta regular
graph very much like like whatever is
there for the spin models that you are
looking at the interaction matrix and
you are looking at these induced matrix
norm and some of the maximizers of the
matrix norms tell you the behavior of
the model on random Delta regular graph
ok so I'm done
I have a simple person I just checked
sanity check if I understood what you
said sort of right so if you switch
signs of you that but if it's 1 minus
big over end to a number of negative
number of monochromatic edges then for
the mean-field model you want the number
of edges of each color to be the same
earthly desires you want to have as many
modern chromatic edges as possible right
because it's a effective so minus minus
is like plus so it's like something
bigger than one to the number of
monochromatic edges Connecticut it only
matters how many edges of each one
automatic color Davis in the mesial more
correct but but that's right and you
don't distinguish now swenson line has
difficulty reducing the size of the
largest color passing sometimes because
you switch for all component all right
all right lovely switches it very slowly
but he does end up changing the number
of vertices with each other a little
better than Spencer winder you know you
you have to resort to variant to that
Sansa bank actually goes to you mean you
mean at the uniqueness
I'd be monitored but it's too late go
away
so how big are the color class is where
I mean you can always separate one
vertex it's going to happen right and
then you're just going to recolor the
vertex so the Swenson length should be
faster than the global dynamics suppose
it should be but the largest color class
instance of line would only tend to
increase right I mean it depends where
you are right so so so if you if you are
if you are what's beyond the uniqueness
and you are close to this majority fixed
point you are going to stick around
there but global dynamics is going to do
the same but i guess the interesting
thing is that if you go beyond here then
the only interesting configurations are
where there is a big color class and
then the Swenson rank is moving between
them quickly
the problem is a second moment
population does it apply to all
constraint functions or do a law 0
always say we have [ __ ] matchings hmm
i think yes but i would have to check i
mean i worked on the assumption that all
the entries a knife are positive but i
would think it should work
well that's right sorry I I I don't have
I don't have a nice Holland problem
where let's say I would convict sure
that it's computationally hard I mean
you can cook up examples where you look
at the Holland problem and you look at
this expression I was going to have two
Maxima let's say if you look at
symmetric want problems with delta equal
3 1 if you go beyond one-fifth below
one-fifth you are going to have two
Maxima so the global dynamics is going
to be slow if you go about one-fifth you
have just one peak if the global
dynamics fast I have no clue
conditioning that's that's right i mean
to get a statement of this you have to
do some extra work beyond matching the
second moment to the square of the first
moment that I so there is some extra
work involved to get a high probability
statement
okay thank you very much